bonjour prémontées que j'ai 18 ans
j'habite à sa minute ils recherchent un
contrat en alternance pour préparer un
bac pro commerce de dix ans après vente
un produit courant j'ai effectué cette
semaine de stage comme vendeur chez
sauve et au strict web et la tripe des
stocks 106 mille qualités sont que suite
ont tué l'année souriant et surtout
motivés dans le travail en équipe
contactez moi je suis très très motivé
je voudrais connaître de domaine ce
travail jude est beaucoup beaucoup
travaillé et a montré un des proches que
je peux avancer et que je peux montrer
tous tout ce que j'ai je suis beaucoup
beaucoup motivé apprenez mois